Welcome.
I'm excited to be talking to you today
again about something very near and dear
to most of us happiness.
Um,
we know that happiness is something
that's been ingrained in our society as
humans for many, many, many years.
If we look back at ancient philosophical
writings by Aristotle, he said,
happiness is the meaning
and the purpose of life,
the whole aim and end of human existence.
Likewise,
the Dalai Lama has
indicated that in many ways,
the very motion of our
life is towards happiness.
So indeed as humans,
we seem to have this insatiable desire
or yearning to be happy and to understand
happiness better.
Today though,
I want to talk about perhaps unusual
and understudied aspect of happiness.
So this is our third segment and our
module on happiness and wellbeing.
And it's the day we'll be looking at
what I refer to as the dark side of
happiness. So in other
words, can feeling good,
sometimes be bad for us.
So we'll start with this unusual question
of the dark side of happiness followed
by our takeaway questions
and expert interview.
So when we think about happiness,
it seems to be something that
we all want to understand.
And indeed we see an increase scientific
focus on happiness with magazines
coming out about the science of happiness
as well as a flooding of pop culture.
Attention on happiness.
We see books like the happiness project,
stumbling on happiness,
authentic happiness,
the how of happiness, the
art of happiness. And a
recent favorite of mine. Um,
get happy today.
I'm with a dolphin soaring out of the
water suggesting that maybe our interest
in happiness is being taken to an all new,
potentially dangerous level.
Um,
we also see an obsession with,
perhaps you might argue happiness
in our pharmaceutical industry.
So we see sales for a
host of antidepressants
skyrocketing in recent years,
including prescriptions for Prozac,
Paxil and Cymbalta.
And there's no surprise in many ways
that we would want to be trying to attain
happiness. So we see a growing
work of psychologist, you know,
really pointing to many of the
key benefits of feeling happy.
This includes building, you
know, vital social bonds,
enhancing our creative thinking and even
building physical immunity. Distressors.
So, even though we know all these
robust benefits of feeling positive,
should this upward pointing trend
towards greater and greater degrees of
happiness always be our desired goal?
Or should we pause,
maybe take a step back and perhaps ask
ourselves just for a moment whether or
not happiness is always a good thing.
So I think we should, and that's what I'm
going to try to convince you of today.
Because in life we always know that
there's two sides to every story.
And why should happiness
be any exception to that?
So in many ways when we think about this,
people often refer to this as trying to
look at the other side of happiness or
you know, you might consider as
the dark side of happiness, right?
So I don't know how many of you
are star wars fans out there,
but for those of you who are,
perhaps what we're doing is really looking
at the Darth Vader side of happiness
here. So when we think about
the dark side of happiness,
one way to begin our journey and to really
grasping the central themes of it is
again going back to Aristotle,
who seemed to have the most amazing
pressing observations about emotions of
anyone.
So he said,
getting angry or sad is
easy and anyone can do it,
but doing it in the right amount at the
right time and in the right way is not
easy, nor can everyone
do it. So this quote,
although it talks about anger and sadness,
highlights three key themes I want
to walk through with you today,
apply to happiness. So some codes
looking at the amount of happiness,
the timing for happiness, and the way
in which we tried to become happy.
So this will constitute the three core
themes as we journey into the dark side
of happiness.
So this includes the amount of happiness,
the timing for when we're happy,
and the way in which we become happy.
So let's begin with our
first core team here.
Looking at the amount of happiness and
asking the question together of whether
there can ever be too much of
a good thing like happiness.
So recent work has suggested that the
relation ship between our happiness on the
bottom and our psychological health as
you can see here over on the left is not
straightforward or linear and instead
it actually seems to mimic more of what
you can think of as an upside
down or inverted u shape.
So I'll walk you through
what this looks like.
So you can see in many ways that as
happiness increases as we saw earlier in
that upward pointing Arrow to some
extent is our happiness increases.
We see at at, um, sort of advantages
for our psychological health socially,
cognitively, and even physically. However,
this truism about happiness seems to
only hold up to what I think of as a
certain tipping point.
And after that point it seems that the
benefits of happiness actually begin to
unravel.
Um,
and our psychological health actually
goes down and this continues downwards
until we reach what we think of as the
potential dark side of positive emotion
or where we begin to see happiness
associated with a variety of negative
outcomes when it's experienced that too
extreme of a degree or where perhaps
there's too much of a good thing.
So I'll give you some examples here.
So what we see is that as happiness
increases to greater and greater levels,
um, it actually shows
decreases and creativity.
So we no longer see positive
mood facilitating this sort
of creative exploratory
thought. When it's experienced
at a heightened level,
it actually impedes our
ability to think creatively.
It also is associated with increased
rates of a, of maladaptive behaviors.
We see heightened levels of positivity
associated with increased risk taking
behavior,
alcohol and drug use,
as well as increased
risk for mental illness.
And in particular we've studied in my
lab a particular form of psychopathology
referred to as a mania, which is a
core component of bipolar disorder.
I'll show you a quote now that illustrates
in what way too much positivity can
be associated with mental illness.
Such as bipolar disorder.
So I think this quote here illustrates
that theme really nicely. It says,
the case for the dangers of positive
emotions is made most straightforwardly by
individuals with mania.
There joy is infectious,
their optimism and self
confidence unbounded.
One manic may give away his life savings
on a whim while another joyfully drives
a hundred miles an hour to a sexual
liaison with the potentially dangerous
stranger.
So here we can see that a
heightened amount of positive
mood and mania contently
to risky and even dangerous outcomes.
So when we look at this graph here,
again,
what it suggests is that this upside down,
you suggest that happiness is by and
large good up until we hit a critical
tipping point.
And beyond that certain point,
it indeed maybe too much of a good thing.
So now let's look at the timing here.
We're going to ask the question of can
there ever be a wrong time for happiness?
Are there certain contexts or places
where it may not be to our advantage to be
feeling happy?
So here what I'm going to suggest is
that happiness is not adaptive in every
context.
And instead it seems to be specifically
tuned for situations that involve
building resources, savoring,
achievements, and cementing social bonds.
But that's not every context
of our everyday life.
And so indeed there may be wrong
times for feeling happiness.
I'll provide you with
a couple of examples.
One example is situations
that are competitive. So here,
recent work by Maya Tamir has found that
people induced to experience a happy
mood, actually perform worse on tasks
that require competition or confrontation.
In her study, she looked at
a competitive video game, um,
that people perform worse
on this competitive video
game compared to individuals
who are actually induced
into an angry mood state.
So when we need to confront
someone or compete,
we actually seem to do worse
when we're in a happy mood,
especially when we compare
it with an angry mood state.
Another important context
is one involving loss.
So we can probably all
readily imagine how that,
how feeling happy during the situation
of loss would impede our ability to
appreciate the absent object or person
or if imagine a loved one came to a
screening and we respond to them with
like a smiling expression on our face,
how that would not only hinder
our connection with them,
but it would impede our
ability to actually empathize
with them and comfort them
in their time of mourning.
So work in my lab has really looked at
this particular context and found that
individuals who are experiencing
heightened positive mood
while they're watching
films of a young boy crying
over the deck of his father,
that is those individuals are at greater
risk for developing mood disorders
later on in their life.
We've also found that individuals,
when they're watching other people share
moments of personal suffering and loss,
either with a romantic partner in the
room or watching a video of a real live
human telling a story about the
time that their mother passed away,
that those individuals who are at a
greater risk for developing mood disorders
like mania indeed seem to show greater
positive emotion experience and even
perceived other people to be feeling
more positive in these contexts.
So it suggests that feeling positive
in competitive situations causes you to
perform worse in those situations.
Whereas feeling positive in situations of,
you know,
very clear loss or suffering or tragedy
put you at risk for developing mood
disorders later on in life such as mania.
So let's turn to our final team
here. Looking at the way, by the way,
what we're really talking about here,
it's concluding with the question of
whether or not there can never be wrong
ways to find or pursue
happiness. And here, um,
again,
we'll return to this idea we've talked
about in our earlier lectures of this
ingrained in all of us.
You know,
especially in the u s and then our own
declaration of independence even is this
notion of life,
liberty and the pursuit of happiness.
And even though this is a core kind
of central cultural value of ours,
should we stop for a moment in question
whether or not we ought to always strive
to be happy?
And indeed research suggests that yes,
we really should consider that the way
we pursue happiness may actually set us
up to be less happy.
So original work here was done by iris
mouse at UC Berkeley where she found that
those individuals who endorsed
high degrees of valuing
the pursuit of happiness,
so saying that was very important for
them to be feeling happy and they put
great efforts and expended great
effort to try to attain happiness,
that it's these individuals who actually
set themselves up with higher standards
for being happy.
And as a result she argues are likely
to experience disappointment when such
standards are not met.
And this is most apparent in positive
situations such as watching a happy film
where you might desire or
expect to be feeling happy.
So this paradoxical pursuit of happiness,
she would say is that those people who
value happiness the most and expanding
the most effort to pursue and attain it
actually may set themselves up for less
happy lives.
And in work with Iris Nelson colleagues,
our lab has found that those individuals
who actually endorse valuing happiness
the most are also those
individuals who report greater, um,
reports of symptoms of depression. So
they're actually the most depressed. Um,
we also have looked at work in
individuals with bipolar disorder as well,
who also endorse heightened
levels of valuing happiness.
So both for the general population that
seems not to be an ideal strategy and
seems to also characterize individuals
diagnosed with or at risk for mood
disorders such as depression
and bipolar disorder. So again,
it seems that we always turn back
to ancient scholars, uh, when we,
when we find these conclusions,
um,
who has suggested early on John Stuart
mill that those only are happy who have
their minds fixed on some object
other than their own happiness.
So where should we go then in
our ultimate quest for happiness?
So we see this idea of accepting your
happiness as it is, wherever that is.
And I want to leave you with
three take home points. First,
I hope that you take home the idea that
happiness is a critical ingredient of
what makes us human and
gives meaning to our lives.
There's nothing inherently
bad and happiness per se,
but which is the second point.
We need to treat happiness with care
and be mindful to experience it in
moderation.
So not too much at the right time,
which is not all the time
and in the right way.
So letting it come naturally rather than,
you know,
obsessing over finding happiness
and maximizing it. And finally,
the third point is that it's critical
to find the right tools for attaining
happiness. And this is what I
allude to in this quote here.
So one of them being sort of radical
acceptance of your current state.
So this sort of traces back to ancient
Buddhist traditions that really suggests
that rather than trying
to strive for happiness,
to simply accept your happiness as it is,
wherever that is.
And this perhaps is the true secret to
happiness. And a way to sort of, you know,
get away or bypass some of the dark sides
of happiness that we've talked about
in our lecture today. If you'd like to
see more of me talking on this topic,
you can go here.
This is something that myself and my
lab spend a lot of time thinking about.
So now I'll conclude with our takeaway
questions and expert interview.
So our takeaway questions
today go as follows. First,
can there ever be too much of a good
thing when it comes to happiness and
related feelings of positive emotion?
Second,
what is the wrong timing for happiness?
What contexts or times is it not in our
advantage to be feeling happy or good?
And finally, what is the paradoxical
pursuit of happiness discussed today?
And to what extent does this suggest
that we should be striving to be happy?
So now we'll turn to our expert interview
as part of our experts and emotion
interview series today for our
experts and emotion interview.
We have the pleasure of speaking with
Dr Maya to Mirror on the dark side of
positive emotion.
Dr Tamir is an assistant professor and
the director of the emotion and self
regulation laboratory at the
Hebrew University of Jerusalem.
She completed her undergraduate
degree at Tel Aviv University,
received her phd from the University
of Illinois at Urbana Champagne,
and completed her post doctoral
training at Stanford University.
Dr Tamir is most interested
in understanding what
motivates people to regulate
their emotions and in her quest,
she studies the implications of both
pleasant and unpleasant emotional
experiences and people's beliefs,
thoughts, and feelings about emotions.
So I'll now turn to a very special
emotion and expert interview with my
colleague, Dr Maya Tamir on the
dark side of positive emotion.